Companies are being overwhelmed by data.
Suddenly they have all sorts of
information about their customers,
their employees, about financial markets.
But what are you going to do with that?
How do you harvest that data and
put it to work for your company so
that you make better decisions?
[MUSIC]
There are a lot of executives out
there who know they have this data.
They have some analytical ability,
but they're not experts on it.
And we want to help them think about
the processes, the procedures, and
the tools out there.
How do I get the right information and
put it to use in a way that's going to be
valuable, it's going to be actionable,
it's going to make
the company work better?
>> I wanted to learn more about big data,
how to make decisions
with help of big data.
>> This program provides you with
deep insights on how you can use
big data at the heart of your
business strategies to make
better management
decisions on many fronts.
>> The role of the executive
has never been more important.
As we fill up the ranks of firms and
engineering staffs with people who
are really amazing at writing
great computer code and
making predictions, at using the data,
it becomes ever more important to
have powerful leaders in the room.
Who can ask, are we really even
trying to predict the right thing?
Are we going after the right metric?
>> The ideal participant for Big Data,
Strategic Decisions Analysis to Action,
is a senior manager.
They want to know, how do I interface with
my data scientists, my market analysts?
How do I take the data and
how do I make my company run better?
>> As opposed to be being
down in the details,
we have an amazing team that does that.
But as a leader I really wanted to
understand how can that aid with my
decision making.
>> If those executives can compliment
those skills they already have with
knowledge of what big data can do for
that business, that's an opportunity for
those people to take their careers and
their businesses to the next level.
Throughout the week you will spend time
working on a team to try to solve
an actual problem using real data.
>> The real data challenge is,
it's very intense.
There is a lot of interaction.
>> We had very interesting guest speakers.
>> People who actually employ this big
data techniques in their companies.
>> How they evolved with time.
How they used the big data to
improve their product offering.
>> This is where innovation happens,
and that is special here.
And that's something you feel.
>> It's really the seasoned manager who
can provide balance to the automation and
the algorithms.
And also can see the big picture in terms
of what's the purpose of this company?
Where are we going?
What do we stand for?
What are our values?
>> Data is ruling so we really need
to understand what that means and
what that looks like and how we can
potentially impact our businesses.
>> I think this program will give me
a competitive advantage in the way I can
approach people about
big data problems now.
I have more confidence.
>> The right knowledge to
make some business better is
always a competitive advantage.
>> The opportunity to go back and effect
change in my organization, being among
thought leaders who are experts in their
field, strong leaders in their field.
To hear what's happening in their worlds,
in their businesses, and
how can I maybe leverage some of that?
>> This is something that's
a once in a lifetime experience.
You get to be on campus,
meet with people who are incredibly
impressive and incredibly knowledgeable.
>> Do it [LAUGH] do it,
you really can't afford not to.
[MUSIC]